Fabian wir machen Spezial zum Thema
Zucker da will ich nicht schon wieder
direkt ein Politiker fragen wie wir es
immer machen ja beruhigt dich sehe ich
ganz genauso deswegen habe ich uns
direkt einen Termin bei meinem Hausarzt
organisiert okay gute Idee
hallo Herr Doktor sie kommen zu mir in
die Sprechstunde
[Musik]
ein ganz normaler Tag in der heute show
Sommerpause wir treffen uns essen viel
zu große bunte Lollis füttern uns
gegenseitig mit Zuckerwatte und lassen
Bonbons vom Himmel regnen denn wir
lieben ihn sogar
und seit neuestem redet sogar die
Politik über Zucker ja wegen diesen
verschrobenen durchgeknallten
Besserwissern die behaupten Zucker sei
gar nicht so gut äh du meinst Ärzte ja
genau die einer von ihnen ist der
Diabetologe Professor Dr Martin und
weißt du was Lutz an denen habe ich
direkt eine super Frage glaube ich zwar
nicht aber schießlos haben den Zucker
und Diabetes was miteinander zu tun
Zucker führt zu Übergewicht und führt zu
Typ 2 Diabetes also wenn jemand viel
Zucker ist und wird nicht dick dann
kriegt er auch keinen Typ 2 Diabetes man
muss es doch so drastisch sagen die
ganze Welt wird immer fetter oder ja das
ist ein weltweites Problem aus
Adipositas aus massiven übergewicht
entsteht nicht nur Diabetes sondern die
Gelenke halten das lange nicht aus sind
dann haben wir
Tumorerkrankungen Herzinfarkt
Schlaganfall das heißt da wird ganz ganz
viel ausgelöst und das führt zu kosten
das ist doch eine gute Nachricht die
fetten Jahre sind gar nicht vorbei ja
die fetten Jahre für die Medizin für die
Gesundheit fürs Gesundheitswesen die
kommen noch weil
wir werden Dich arbeitslos also von der
Seite her aber man muss doch auch sagen
es ist immer schwieriger geworden sich
gesund zu ernähren weil Zucker ist doch
heutzutage überall drin oder ja wir
werden Zucker überall zugesetzt das ist
eine Sache das haben wir natürlich nur
dort wo Fertigprodukte nehmen wenn ich
in einem Supermarkt gehe irgendwas aus
dem rheingal rauszuholen weiß ich nicht
was drin ist wenn man hinten drauf guckt
da steht alles so verklausuliert drin
das ist sogar für mich als Experte
schwierig ist ähm aber ein paar
Beispiele wo über Zucker drin ist ich
habe jetzt von Patienten erfahren dass
er eben gekochten Schinken Zucker drin
ist da hat er ehrlich gesagt gar nichts
zu suchen oder wenn man so ein
Heringssalat ist dann denkt man super
Heringssalat das ganz viel Zucker dran
ja also von der Seite und das ist
interessant unsere Patienten die immer
ihren Blutzucker messen die sagen dann
weiß ich da habe ich ein Peak da weiß
ich aha dabei sein
und auf einmal ist der Arzt gar nicht
mehr so nett denn er will mit einem
Sensor unsere Blutzuckerwerte messen und
das zwei Wochen lang toller Moment die
Lügenpresse wird live im Fernsehen
gecheckt moment mal das heißt wir können
uns ab jetzt nur noch süßen Kram
reinpfeifen und das alles im Namen der
Wissenschaft ja genau geil
wir haben jetzt noch 59 Minuten Zeit bis
uns die App komplett den Spaß am Essen
verdirbt Eiskaffee Eiskaffee ciao
gute Nachrichten der Homo sapiens hat es
endlich wieder geschafft und eine neue
Entwicklungsstufe gezündet
57% der Erwachsenen hierzulande sind
mittlerweile zu dick kein Wunder denn
der durchschnittliche Mitbürger sitzt
viel zu oft einfach gemütlich im
Schaukelstuhl und sagt sehr sehr
Schokolade und damit eben auch Zucker
und der ist überall inzwischen sind 80%
aller industriell hergestellten
Lebensmittel zusätzlich mit Zucker
angereichert Sie haben richtig gehört
80% und im Zucker sind sogar 100 %
Zucker kein Wunder dass jeder Deutsche
im Durchschnitt täglich 32 Würfelzucker
ist also fast doppelt so viel wie von
der WHO empfohlen aber gut was weiß sie
wer auch schon da steht ja nur
fürs Organisation keine Ahnung was das
auf deutsch heißt die Folgen heute haben
schon über 8 Millionen Deutsche Diabetes
Typ 2 jeder 7 Todesfall ist doch
ungesunde Ernährung suchen die
wirtschaftlichen Kosten von Adipositas
betragen jährlich 63 Milliarden Euro und
viele Deutsche können sogar nur noch im
Sitzen Arbeiten hallo und herzlich
willkommen zur heute-show ja ja schlimme
Bilder laut WHO haben Übergewicht und
Fettleibigkeit in Europa ein
epidemisches Ausmaß erreicht da müsste
man mal mit jemandem darüber sprechen
der sich mit Epidemien auskennt oder in
der Tat hier bin ich mehr als die Hälfte
der Erwachsenen ist zu dick tatsächlich
brauchen wir einen Lockdown für
Süßigkeiten
nee mit einem Lockdown bin ich erstmal
durch das also das hat schon stimmen
ohne Ende gekostet das ist nicht die
aber wir brauchen super Schlagsahne
Lauterbach für Süßigkeiten einschließen
aber
tatsächlich wir müssen etwas machen
jetzt starke erstmal die Zahl der
Übergewichtigen deren schwerer
Erkrankung kommt er sind 10 15 20 Jahren
von jetzt das heißt die übersichtswelle
die wir jetzt haben die wird das
Gesundheitssystem ist in 20 30 Jahren
stark belasten zum einen haben wir den
Milliardenmarkt für den Zucker und auf
der anderen Seite werden wir den
Milliarden Markt haben für Medikamente
die den Konsequenzen des Zuckerkonsums
begegnen würden wir auf den Zucker
verzichten bräuchten wir die Medikamente
nicht also Zucker wirkt negativ in jedem
Winkel kann man sagen in jedem Winkel
des Körpers also sowas wie FDP kann man
sagen ja das ist aber die FDP also
tut das Richtige und das so wir sind in
einer fortschrittskultur überlegt haben
sie das gerade wirklich gesagt können
wir sie so zitieren die FDP tut das
richtig genau
sie überlegt haben sollen wir die
rausschneiden nein nein das kam spontan
das kann
jetzt sprechen wir die ganze Zeit über
die schlechten Seiten von Zucker was
sind denn die positiven Seiten ne wenn
Sie doch mal zehn bis 20 Beispiele ich
bringe meinen also Beispiel wenn Kinder
also Süßigkeiten essen das ist aber
wenig und einigermaßen gesund das macht
ja riesen Spaß daran erinnert man sich
ja auch also ich habe zum Beispiel ich
kam aus seiner Familie war relativ arm
und ich habe als Kinder sehr gerne Mars
Schokolade gegessen diese Maßregeln und
wir hatten aber so wenig Geld dass ich
halt nicht den ganzen Regel essen konnte
dann wurde der Regel geteilt ich muss
den Regel dann teilen wodurch das
schwarze Papier geteilt mit meiner
Schwester und dann habe ich immer so
geteilt dass man nicht besser ein
Stückchen mehr bekam sehr großzügig
sowas natürlich nicht
also das sind schöne Moment ich erinnere
mich heute noch daran
laut der Uni Hamburg wir laufen sich ja
die gesamtgesellschaftlichen Kosten der
Adipositas in Deutschland auf etwa 63
Milliarden Euro pro Jahr das stimmt also
seine gut gemachte Studie die Hälfte
ungefähr also ist
verbraucht durch die Medizin die da
notwendig wird die Operationen die also
Behandlungen die Medikamente und so
weiter und so und die andere Hälfte geht
verloren durch die verlorene Arbeitszeit
zählt man all diese Kosten verlorenen
Arbeitszeit mit hinein ist man bei den
über 60 Milliarden bei Alkohol sind nur
57 Milliarden also Zucker ist
schädlicher als Alkohol der gleichen
Lina ja ja da kann man also sagen Mai
Tai statt Ü-Ei ja also der Unterschied
ist klein oder Korn statt Flakes das ist
richtig
oh Gott
das Ganze im Schlaganfall führen und
dann wäre es dann wirklich so also
Herren k.o durch Harry Potter so Fabian
du musst jetzt ganz stark sein Zucker
ist nicht nur in Süßigkeiten
sondern auch in deinem absoluten
lieblingsessen
nein der ist ohne Ende Zucker drin in
dem Pizzen ich treffe ZDF besseresser
Sebastian lege er nimmt Lebensmittel
auseinander guck was drin ist und baut
sie wieder zusammen das ist wirklich
mein allergrößtes
nee weil die Kinder animiert werden
oder habe ich eine extreme Abneigung
geben
egal
ich habe seine lieblingsbezogen
mitgebracht das ist die wo ist hier die
steingroßen Pizza Spezial und die ist ja
jetzt guck mal
weißt du eigentlich das gerade bei so
Wurstwaren ja
ich war klar Schweinefleisch Leute Salz
solltet ihr auch ein ja dritte Zutat
Dextrose Zuckerstoff
14 % zu Besetzer Zucker
14%
warum warum
umso mehr Zucker umso länger haltbar ist
der Konservierungsstoff Nummer 1
überall weißt du warum solche Produkte
so richtig gut laufen und ein absoluter
profitmaker sind bei so Leute wie dich
gehen
und jetzt wagen wir das Unmögliche wir
backen eine Pizza mit und eine ohne
Zuckerzusatz
[Musik]
ich finde der Unterschied ist minimal
oder klar genau vom Geschmack kann man
sich Zucker komplett sparen richtig für
die erstmal interessant aber hier ist
das wichtig das Produkt auch die
Fließeigenschaft Zucker ist auch ein
Stabilisator Zucker wie du siehst ne
guck mal
richtig hart er gibt mir auch ein
gewisses Gerüst an Stabilität
[Musik]
ich habe das wirklich noch nie gemacht
jetzt lass mich doch mal machen ich muss
mich doch erstmal da rein finden erstmal
richtig Mehlen ja so und auch hier den
Lümmel auch mal die einreiben da den
Lümmel einreiben das hast du nicht
wirklich gesagt
[Musik]
wie lange denn noch Sebastian wie lange
noch wie lange dauert es denn noch wie
lange noch Verletzung wird auf alle
Fälle bestraft oder
ich finde ohne Scheiß optisch schon mal
absolut ähnlich ich nehme so ein schönes
Stück ja das ist erstmal die Variante
mit Zucker
also ich muss sagen Kompliment schmeckt
genauso oder jetzt mal die ohne
man schmeckt schon Unterschied voll ich
hätte nicht gedacht wie viel Zucker dann
doch ausmacht im Geschmack ich finde
hier die schmeckt richtig süß ja genau
aber das fällt einem jetzt auch erst auf
finde ich im Direktvergleich wie viel
das dann doch ausmacht und es schmeckt
leider auch mit Zucker es schmeckt
besser oder Scheiße wir sehen ein Kind
in seinem natürlichen Habitat es ist
umgeben von Süßigkeiten und von Werbung
für Süßigkeiten denn 92 % der
lebensmittelwerbung die Kinder im
Fernsehen und Internet wahrnehmen
beziehen sich auf Süßigkeiten Snacks
oder Fast Food kein Wunder also dass
unsere kleinen nichts anderes im Kopf
haben
durchaus eher Team Popcorn aber auch für
Nachos zu haben
backbohnen mit Butter ja inzwischen sind
über 15% aller Kinder und Jugendlichen
übergewichtig 6% sogar an die bös
weswegen sie mir Werbung für ungesunde
Produkte die sich explizit an Kinder
richtet verbieten will und nein sie
haben nicht das versehene Forsthaus
Falken umgeschaltet das ist wirklich es
ist mir aber ist so ein Werbeverbot
überhaupt umsetzbar wer weiß immerhin
steht es in diesem sagen Buch von der
Mütter richtig dem Ampel
Koalitionsvertrag trotzdem ist eine
dieser Parteien jetzt gegen das
vereinbarte Werbeverbot also jetzt mal
ganz ehrlich die FDP ist dagegen haben
sie das kommen sehen nein eigentlich
und noch einer ist dagegen die
Süßwarenindustrie einmal im Jahr ist das
große Familientreffen in Köln da wird
gedealt was das Zeug hält die werden
doch sicher einige gute Argumente für
Zucker parat haben was sind denn so die
drei besten Eigenschaften von Zucker
es ist süß es schmeckt gut und
Nummer drei muss ich jetzt schon
überlegen was halten Sie von diesem
Werbeverbot was da jetzt ins Spiel
gebracht wird
ich sage mal das ist eine schlimme
Bevormundung der Menschen und eine
Verdummung der Menschen weil man
verpackt das als ein kinderwerbeverbot
aber letztendlich betrifft das alle
Kategorien nicht nur süß waren die auf
Kinder wo die Werbung vielleicht auf
Kinder ziehen gerichtet ist sondern es
betrifft letztendlich auch Müslis die zu
viel Zucker enthalten es betrifft alle
Lebensbereiche
Prime wo wollen wir dann aufhören also
wo kommen wir da langsam mal hin bei den
Grünen jetzt wollen sie sogar dass wir
unsere kindergesund ernähren ja das
stimmt in Großbritannien gibt es ja seit
ein paar Jahren eine Zuckersteuer was
halten Sie von dem Ansatz in Dänemark
gibt es auch so eine Steuer eine
sogenannte Zuckersteuer und wir haben
teilweise den höchsten Verbrauch an
Süßwaren in der in Dänemark pro Kopf
gleichzeitig ist in Großbritannien ja
dann der Zuckeranteil runtergegangen in
den Produkten ne das kann ich Ihnen
nicht sagen deswegen sage ich Ihnen ja
okay das weiß ich nicht das zeigt ja
schon dass es was bewirkt
gut wenn der Zuckeranteil runter geht
[Musik]
ob das jetzt direkt damit zusammenhängt
kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen also es wurde
2001 es könnte schon Zusammenhang sein
richtig aber man höhere Steuern zahlt
dass man dann noch ne dass man das
versuchen das kann ich jetzt könnten
Zusammenhang sein aber beweisen können
wir es nicht ich war ich ich kenne dazu
wenig Fakten dazu kann ich eigentlich
aber ich sie können mir vertrauen ne
weiß ich nicht
hier vom great Briten welcome to Germany
thank you wir haben uns jetzt in Great
Britain you have a Texas for sugar sind
hier in Germany where you can do sugar
at much is you want in your product oder
muss
you're welcome und während Fabian in
Germany schlechtes Englisch redet
versuche ich das mal in Brüssel
europaweit der Ort mit den meisten
Lobbyisten hier gibt es sogar
lobby-organisationen für
Verbraucherschutz also eine eine einzige
how many sugar Lobby hier the lobby in
favor of sugar production
the farmers than you have the sugar
Lobby the sugar produces das spezifiki
than you have food drink Europe
I can tell you that in times of the
compares
like Asterix
auf der product so
whiled
to go for business Brother than for
health when I was in the European
palment and
for people
the name
Nutella people love it
from Italie kostenlos
[Musik]
die Süßwaren und Zuckerindustrie gibt
allein in Deutschland 4,5 Millionen Euro
für Lobbyismus aus pro Jahr da wird doch
wohl auch ein bisschen was für mich
rausbringen allein in diesem Gebäude
hier hinter mir in der Avenue den ja
sitzen vier lobbyistenverbände nämlich
die Association of tropicals and
confectionary industries of Europe
European breakfast serial Association
footing Europe und das Komitee of the
European sugar User da wird mich doch
einer einstellen oder
[Musik]
hallo mein Name ist Lutz vanaus from
Germany and I wanna be a member of the
sugar Lobby
ähm
very good contacts
Julia Klöckner hier genau Olaf Scholz
schenzeler
Herr Lauterbach dran
insgesamt würde ich sagen es lief gut
wir sind jetzt erstmal in Kontakt also
haben jetzt so E-Mail-Verkehr erstmal
aber ich mache sicherheitshalber erst
noch mal heute schon dann gucken wir
noch mal später
so jetzt reden wir endlich mal mit den
Betroffenen den Kindern ist doch super
Fabian dann kannst du endlich mal
Gespräche auf Augenhöhe führen wie ist
das denn wenn ihr einkaufen geht könnt
ihr euch dann einfach Süßigkeiten nehmen
welche nehmen aber dann werden die
wieder zurückgestellt
was ist denn euer absolutes
Lieblingsessen
warum sind denn Süßigkeiten so lecker
oder so keine Ahnung
der Zucker zieht die Kinder ja an meine
Mutter versteckt sie sich keinen in
einen Schrank aber das ist ein
furchtbarer Versteck weil du es kennst
ja und was sind die Verstecke wo du die
Süßigkeiten vor dein Geschwistern die
gucken die Sendung ähnlich die kommt zu
spät kannst jetzt ruhig sagen aber meine
Mutter ach so ja immer noch geheim
bleiben
für Süßigkeiten
also freiwillig nicht wir zeigen euch
jetzt Süßigkeiten und ihr müsst raten
wie viele Würfelzucker sind in diesen
Süßigkeiten zum Beispiel
Kinderschokolade das glaubt ihr wie
viele sind drin
also in der ganzen Packung hier drin
sagst du wie viele sind drin
das sind nämlich 14 und dann noch mal
vier das alles ist in dieser Packung
Kinderschokolade drin
also so viele Würfel passen ja gar nicht
mal hier rein also wir haben hier diese
Packung das ist jetzt in dem Fall Banane
Kirsch rate doch mal wie viel
Würfelzucker sind in dieser kleinen
Packung drin
das ist falsch denn es sind 15 16 17
wieder drauf sind sollte man wenn man
ehrlich ist die Früchte wegmachen und
einfach hier so diese Zuckerwürfel da
drauf drücken
aber würdet ihr das dann trotzdem noch
kaufen wenn das so ehrlich wäre dann
lassen wir doch lieber die Früchte drauf
da isst du gerne Gummibärchen
eine große Packung Gummibärchen 1000
Gramm Gummibärchen und du musst jetzt
mal raten wie viel Würfelzucker sind in
dieser Packung Gummibärchen okay da
mache ich mal mehr als letztes Mal
okay
[Musik]
es sind natürlich
das hätte jetzt nicht gedacht
wieder ein Kind verstört
bis 2035 könnte mehr als die Hälfte der
gesamten Menschheit dann Übergewicht und
Adipositas leiden weswegen viele Staaten
nein greifen Werbung für ungesundes die
sich ein Kinder richtet wurde schon
eingeschränkte Ländern wie Griechenland
und Australien in Schweden Norwegen und
Kanada ist die komplett verboten und in
Chile geht man sogar noch weiter
zusätzlich haben dort alle Produkte mit
zu viel Zucker Fett und Salz schwarze
wahr Hinweise und in den USA hat man
sogar extra mal ein abschreckendes
Beispiel von zuckermissbrauch zum
Präsidenten gewählt Frühstück so wichtig
sogar ein Großbritannien wird gehandelt
dort gibt es seit 2018 eine Zuckersteuer
für Softdrinks sobald sie mehr als 5g
Zucker pro 100 ml enthalten und
Überraschung auf einmal ist der
Zuckeranteil in der Fanta dort auf 4,6
Gramm pro 100 ml gesunken
in Deutschland sind es übrigens 9 Gramm
jetzt machen und sogar die Engländer
beim Thema Ernährung was für euch meine
die Engländer muss ich mehr sagen also
es gibt doch so viele Möglichkeiten den
Zuckerkonsum zu reduzieren was davon
setzen wir um vielen Dank tschüss
darf man bald noch für Süßigkeiten
werden das fragen wir den Mann der die
Werbung einschränken will
für das Gespräch haben wir extra eine
eigene Werbeagentur gegründet und uns
passend dazu doofe Anzüge und Brillen
aus Fensterglas angezogen warum wird
jetzt eigentlich mehr über Werbung
diskutiert als über die schädlichen
Produkte
weil es ja nicht darum geht dass der
Gemüse die mir den Leuten sagt ist das
Produkt und es das nicht das ist nicht
mein Job das ist entscheiden Sie selber
für Kinder gerne ein paar Tipps aber wir
wollen den Leuten in Frankreich
die Hälfte mit Wasser selber
wollen sie Werbung für Käse verbieten
nein wollen sie Werbung für Müsli
verbieten nein wollen sie Werbung für
Maultaschen verbieten ganz sicher nein
ja wie immer also die Grünen sagen immer
nein ja
bieten wenn Produkte gezielt für Kinder
beworben werden und
jetzt kommt wieder mein Dauerbrenner zu
viel Salz zu viel Zucker oder zu viel
Fett enthalten darum geht es im Kern
nicht alle die zu viel Übergewicht haben
die adipase positas haben haben das
freiwillig entschieden und machen das
gern so das hat was damit zu tun dass es
wissen manchmal nicht vorhanden ist die
Eltern nicht können warum auch immer in
vielen Haushalten wird zu Hause gar
nicht mehr gekocht und ehrlich gesagt
reizt mich das auch und ruft ein
bisschen mein sportlichen Ehrgeiz
hervorzuschauen wer hat eigentlich in
diesem Land die macht eine Koalition die
sich einig durfte etwas was breite
Zustimmung für passiert das oder
passiert das was kleine Einzelgruppen
mit aber sehr viel Geld mit einigen
wenigen Partner in Medien zusammen
bestimmen die das geschickt dieses
Landes oder bestimmt die Mehrheit des
der Menschen in diesem landition die
sich einigt welche Koalition meinte
die Koalition die die in der
Koalitionsvereinbarung der den Auftrag
gegeben hat genau das zu machen aber ich
gebe Ihnen Recht das manche da in
russlückenplagen das passiert uns schon
ein paar mal ja soll vorkommen
das OLAF scholz-syndrom quasi ne das
haben sie gesagt liebe Zuschauer
schnallen Sie sich an es ist soweit wie
kann man in Zukunft noch Werbung für
Süßes machen Antworten gibt der erste
und einzige Elevator Pitch der
brandneuen Werbeagentur Olaf Scholz and
friends Login
wir sind Urlaub
ist immer eine Frage des Angebots
besser eine Tafel Schokolade als zwei
Tafeln Schokolade also das ist mein
blowing würde ich jetzt sagen und das
schon beim ersten Slogan
klassisch Ampel was da steht ja gut
gegen die grün ist mehr Zucker
heißt übrigens Apfel
natürlich sprachlos oder
verwirre deine Eltern ist Gemüse ja das
würde ich meinen Kindern mitgeben
sind einfach so schlagwortete
wir haben ja ihren aktuellen Stand vom
Entwurf auch durchgelesen am Anfang
sollte ja die Werbung zwischen 6 und 23
Uhr verboten werden jetzt ist es aber
ganz einfach
von 17 bis 2 jeden Tag es ist glaube ich
nee samstags ist zusätzlich
auch noch mal anders sonntags von 8 bis
2 guckt wann Kinder gezielt im vor der
Glotze sitzen sehr nicht sehr
übersichtlich wer da nicht wirklich eine
Zuckersteuer irgendwie bisschen
einfacher wir sind Fans von der
Zuckersteuer das ist in England habe ich
irgendwie auch
England funktioniert die essen nur Müll
ja funktioniert bei den Engländern
schaffen
bereits mindestens 85 Länder eine
Zusatzsteuer auf zuckerhaltige Getränke
eingeführt deutschland droht also Teil
einer Minderheit zu werden
würden Sie das bitte auch einige meine
Kollegen in der Koalition ausrichten
vielleicht
hilft sie also man könnte sagen dass wir
weiter diese zuckergetränke saufen ist
deutsches Sprite Kultur hast du da
wirklich Sprite
Kulturen Ländern mit deutlich weniger
Zucker und die verkaufen nicht
schlechter und die Leute beschweren sich
nicht dass sie schlecht das schmeckt es
geht also gesund leben will auswandern
die Ampel macht's nicht wenn wir gesund
leben will dafür sorgen dass ich mich
durchsetze mich unterstützen also
auswandern
[Musik]
Fabian wir haben Problem bei unserem
Film das ist nicht ausgewogen wir reden
immer nur mit Zucker Gegnern aber wir
müssen mit dem Befürwortern reden so
kann Lobby süß waren Industrie FDP nur
Absagen ich folg doch auf Instagram so
eine food Influenza der postete täglich
essensbilder gut den kann ich einfach
mal bei insta Livestream einfach mal
zuschalten mal gucken ich kann mich ja
mal einmischen mit einem Paar Zetteln ne
ja hallo unfassbar wir beide in einem
insta Livestream sie haben heute noch
kein essensbilder auf Instagram gepostet
geht's ihnen gut ja aber ich werde bald
eins plus ich habe hier eine ganz tolle
super ich habe mal nachgezählt sie haben
56 essensbilder allein dieses Jahr auf
Instagram gepostet das heißt 56 Mal gab
es immerhin was gehaltvolles auf ihrem
Kanal mein Problem ist ich esse was ich
esse tatsächlich und ich esse auch gern
das unterscheidet sie ja von den meisten
Menschen ne ich drehe gerade heute schon
Spezial zum Thema Zucker das wäre auch
ein sehr interessantes Thema ne
ja finde ich auch aber ich bin ein
bisschen skeptisch im Moment ich habe
gelesen dass sie jetzt in Berlin
Süßigkeiten verboten machen wollen also
Bewerbung ne so und dann habe ich
irgendwo gelesen dass Karl Lauterbach
sagte Kinder müssen gesünder aussehen
aber jetzt die ganze Zeit im Kopf was
passiert wenn alle Kinder irgendwann so
aussehen sollen Lauterbach 5 Minuten mit
ihm im Münster Livestream und direkt das
erstmal bodyshaming was ist losgehen ich
habe nur quasi alles so aussehen dann
denke ich darüber nach oder darf ich
doch immer aber sie sagen das ja
wirklich Süßigkeiten verbieten aber es
werden noch gar keine Süßigkeiten das
wird doch nichts verboten also wird nur
die Werbung die sich an Kinder richtet
verboten aber aber ich finde es jeden
Spaß verbieten das finde ich so grün
aber er geht es nicht eher darum dass
wir auch die Kinder schützen bei uns gab
es alle sind auch groß geworden also ich
finde es total übertrieben jetzt zu
sagen eine Kindergeneration wird nur
dick wenn es ab und zu mal Gummibärchen
ist übertrieben
in 80 sind aller industriell
verarbeitenden Lebensmittel ist Zucker
mittlerweile drin 80 Prozent sie sehen
doch auch also zwar vielleicht nicht gut
aber sehr gesund aus ich weiß nicht ob
ihre Eltern immer Bio gekauft haben aber
sie haben dieselbe entschieden und ich
finde das einfach übertrieben alles
verboten wird 66% der deutschen
unterstützen ja dieses Werbeverbot für
Zucker und ich habe nur eine größere
Mehrheit aktuell gefunden und zwar sagen
73% Nein zur Aussage Friedrich Merz wäre
ein guter Bundeskanzler also Respekt
ja es war gerade nicht Störung ich habe
es nicht verstanden
die ist aus dem Weißen Haus kennen sie
noch Julia Klöckner erinnern sich noch
an die ja ja selbst die selbst die hat
als Landwirtschaftsministerin
wissenschaftliches Gutachten in Auftrag
gegeben da kam genau das raus
Werbeverbote
finde ich gut aber wieso sind denn dann
66% der Bevölkerung für so ein
Werbeverbot und ich glaube sogar über
80% aller Eltern ich glaube nicht
keine Probleme sonst mit Energie mit
Wohlstand mit Zukunft sorgen und
Wirtschaft nein das ist jetzt die
wichtigste Frage eine Sache noch eine
Sache noch jawohl es ist aber so es ist
so ich habe noch eine Überraschung für
sie oh Gott was denn noch ein guter
Freund von mir ist hier der würde gerne
hallo sagen hallo ich bin auch dabei ihr
macht alles zusammen oder ist halt so
irgendwie ja wir sind schon Freunde auch
und wenn so ein Top-Event ansteht ne
okay wir hatten einfach beide nichts zu
tun so zwei Wochen sind rum Hosen runter
Bauch raus was sagen unsere Zuckerwerte
gut ich gebe ihn einfach mal das Handy
sie können ja mal durchgehen ja gut
hier war irgendwie eine nächtliche
Aktion um 0 Uhr da 0 Uhr isst du noch es
könnte sein dass ich da vielleicht das
ein oder andere alkoholische Getränk
konsumierter was was ein Bier ja
beim Wein wäre nichts passiert aber nur
so als Tipp unter Freunden so dann oh ja
5 August das war hier da ging es richtig
richtig ich hatte so einen Kater dass
ich mir eine Tiefkühlpizza reingehauen
habe ja okay gut also ähm ja es war ein
gutes Wochenende meine gute was wollt
ihr denn nicht für Deinen Körper aber
man muss einfach wissen in dem Moment wo
man übergewichtig ist und man hat so ein
Peak produziert der Körper Insulin und
dann ist für 5 Tage die Fettverbrennung
kaputt fünf Tage echt ja schlimm das
interessante Werte so und so mal gucken
gut das war auch nachts alkoholisches
Getränk nee da bin ich tatsächlich in
den Supermarkt hat mir so ein Eisbecher
so ein Karamell Eisbecher geholt der
Forschung 1 Uhr nachts sehte August was
haben wir da gegen Morgen habe ich mir
einen tu mir mal was Gutes und Essen
Knuspermüsli so ein und macht da noch
schöne Früchte rein mit Milch dachte ich
tue ich mir was Gutes und das ist dieser
Ausschlag da also Müsli als solches ist
für Personen die Gewicht abnehmen wollen
eher ungünstig und abends war Döner
angesagt Döner der für alles der
Forschung Weg ja aber der Döner ist ja
nicht das Problem das war ja nur dieses
drumherum also das Fleisch das hätte gar
nichts gemacht
ja die Pommes mit zu wenig zu wenig
Mayonnaise hat Fett pflanzliche Fette
und hat Protein kann man nichts gegen
sagen also von der Seite es wird das
falsch Alter attackiert ja gut vielen
Dank Herr Doktor ja und sie sind
Diabetologe deswegen ich hoffe wir sehen
uns nie wieder genau
Pommes essen
danke tschüss
ja das war schön aber zum Schluss
bleiben wir immer drei Fragen wie viele
Tassen hat Markus Söder noch im Schrank
haben wir während der Dreharbeiten
Kinder zuckerabhängig gemacht
[Musik]
und warum arbeitet Jim Özdemir nicht bei
einer Werbeagentur jetzt bin ich mein
Spruch gar nicht los geworden
mehr Karate dank Tomate
[Musik]
du Fabian hallo der Selbstversuch mit
der Zucker Überdosis ne
voller Erfolg
guckt euch gern weitere Videos an Zucker
Zucker klickt einfach auf eins der
Videos ich bin sowas